hey let's go tick tock
uh today we're going to go through the
ones i
favorited on my phone because i either
went
or haha check it out i spent 700
a month on an apartment and you could
literally buy a van
because i don't want to live in a
van what
way what
i love this one good energy marshall
just sent me
[Applause]
i'm not doing it baby
they're so dramatic we're like cutting
up this little at the
top of their nails and it's just like
murdering me
[Applause]
oh she sent me another one all right she
asked if i had this tick tock filter
hey work some people too great i want to
try it
see i'm getting actual funny ones now
i think this is what people said in the
beginning it's cringe but then the
algorithm will pick up
don't worry i still go through an
ungodly amount of cringe
for example if you pass somebody at work
you go
right and what you're saying is are you
all right yeah
yeah it took me eight years to learn
you're right
you're right and like what the that
sounds if you actually answer the
question
of then that's
rude i don't want to talk about how
you're feeling
what i'm saying that's just a passing
hello don't actually have the
yeah i didn't know this either this took
me way too long to figure out you're not
supposed to
if someone asks are you all right you're
not supposed to say thank you i'm good
actually it doesn't work like that at
all and i don't understand how we've
gotten here you're right you're right
how is that the proper response i don't
get it
how am i the awkward one i don't get it
you're right you're right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right you're all right you're
right mate you're right mate
they say many times too you can meet the
same person twice in the day and they
just go you're right
oh yeah i remember why i said this
because it didn't make me flinch
whatsoever
and i wanted to show it what is this
why are they pretending like they never
seen it
shut up stop replying this man was being
interviewed by a news team about almost
getting hit by a car
and in the middle of yeah
[Music]
so i i've seen this before and i asked
there's no way this is real and everyone
in the comments like you know it's real
it's the greatest clip of all time no
one will ever be as cool
as that guy right there
oh yeah
this is the greatest tic-tac what is he
saying he's saying so little
but also so much old man
teach us your wisdom
can anyone lip read can anyone tell me
what he says
he seems like he had a lot on his mind
so clearly some old dude just replied
that's exactly what i was trying to say
a little controversial
but i agree man old man of wisdom
teach us your way jerry be nice she's
just
she's just trying to swim don't kiss
yeah she wants to swim jerry
killer
[Music]
is a japanese competition where you
shave wood super thin
the current record for the thinnest
shave is about
four microns which is half the width of
a human red blood cell
i don't i don't remember why i saved
this i think it's the way he's just like
kazurukai or microns which is
i don't care holy i'm so sick of
info
tech talks telling me i don't need to
know they
they shave thin wood who gives a
and i love japan
okay i understand it's an impressive
craftsmanship but
my god are we pretending like this
matters what the
dave would keep with that i didn't ask
the current record
okay i know i sound a little rude but i
didn't ask okay
i don't care about thin shaped wood
[Music]
no no
is this is that the guy from top gear
[Music]
what does that mean i've seen this meme
oh no oh
excuse me i'm part west african he
screams uh-huh
okay who suggests something more
exciting how about that huh
can you just like fine okay
fine anyways interest rates just went up
which means that the money supply has
been short who suggest something more
exciting how about that huh
can you just like fine some great
patrick bateman
uh energy in this i love it
oh yeah he dies spoiler sorry i don't
need to ruin it
he doesn't he does i think he's fine
is that part of the gag for the guy to
run out because then that's brilliant
make it seem like he actually got run
[Music]
over
i don't know i it's not even it makes me
laugh
i only don't let go
bruh i could do this get out of here
right i can do that get out of here
in the uk oh yeah this is great
italy everyone in uk pretending they're
living on a tropical island uk
really out here
we do this in sweden too actually and i
don't understand
why people love sitting outdoors so much
when it's clearly
freezing i get that it's like a
covert thing right but in sweden we do
it regardless and i don't get it
can i scan this hey pewdiepie mean
[Music]
so i saw this it's kind of funny seeing
yourself pop up on tick tock right
but they didn't pick the greatest clip
of all time from subnautica that i had
no one's talking about how funny
this is so i was telling this story how
when i was a child i got scared of
barracudas
so i was fishing smee she pishing uh as
you do as a swedish but i put the egg in
there
looking at the fishes it was all
relaxing it was all nice
it was wonderful it was so cool you
could like swim up to fish and be like
hey
do that uh but then all of a sudden
all the fish is just boom and i was like
oh
that's weird and i'm like out pretty far
as well
like this it was basically like this you
see all the fishes just fly away and i'm
like all right
strange guess fishes do that no they
don't
in out of nowhere comes to giant fish
with teeth sticking out like in my
peripheral nerve
are you kidding me
how is that on the best clip ever
[Music]
and it comes swimming in my peripheral
giant
fish we will never have just perfect
timing
in my peripheral
[Applause]
all right moving on that's a great edit
phenomenal job
i don't know why someone decided to do
this but i just want to say thank you
thank you
[Music]
isn't this a bit cringe
tick tock went hard on uh prince philip
dying which yeah okay
but that's his lame dude it's a b movie
let's send him the bean movie i hear the
whole script
i don't get it dennis what is this what
does this do
in your fancy car oh my gosh i'm
planning an airstrike
what is this what is this i want that
car i want to plant an asteroid oh my
god
it's funny i've forgotten these by this
point your main form of comedy is saying
sheesh
maybe you should think about going into
an engineering degree because comedy
isn't for you
is it just me or
[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going i've actually got
something for you this is the bread that
you asked me to get and you can now
go make me a sandwich
[Music]
top youtubers who are sex dead
shame on you can't believe it i was busy
thinking about
again they don't know how to damage bill
this is the second freaking time
[Music]
it's not real it can't be made it can't
be done so therefore aliens
right tick tock can't fan them they're
being damned
i mean the water is already there did
you know for the dodgeball scene of
billy madison
made in 1995 adam sandler was really
hitting the kids as hard as he could
because as he says and this is a real
quote
hitting kids is funny the director cut
right before they started crying
and some of the parents even got upset
with him what is this
why are you replying go away
shush you're not supposed to be there
anyway i know i'm doing the same thing
moving on
that guy needs an engineering degree no
engineering degree
look at that
something confidently too
[Music]
it's like that scene in uh koino katachi
or whatever
since i've added me in here i feel like
i can really add something
wow thank you wow that's so cool if
girls are so smart
then what's wrong with this video oh i'm
not a girl and i honestly can't tell you
is it the ancient debris you can find
netherright anywhere in the nether
oh my god you didn't know that you
didn't know that you noob it's
just more likely to be more
around 15 19 or whatever remember this
video got 11.6 million views for sliding
a red bull can
into a water jug congrats to this
creator well done
man sometimes it just makes you wonder
congrats to this creator
he just made it into a pewdiepie tech
talk video
by sliding a red ball ball and
to grasp her the greater congrats to
this creator
her house is on fire
[Music]
[Applause]
that mom why would you do that it's
not even funny
her house is on fire child abuse
someone report this please
her house is already getting griefed and
you turn up the tv
not cool you all right i say this
because i wanted to try it out
dolly that was not how you spelled it oh
no it was right there
okay a painting of a capybara
sitting in a field at sunrise
cool the singularity is coming
boys an armchair in the shape of an
avocado
that's kind of sick they have like a
actual fabric looking one
they like caffey barrels huh an extreme
close-up view
sitting in a field that is extreme i'm
not gonna lie
more camping with voxels oh cool
oh yeah this is great peace mister
because looks like
fourth or fifth century scandinavian
possibly a representation of one of the
norse knight gods maybe loki
loki i can't tell if they're joking or
not
do people actually think loki is made by
marvel
oh my god it's canon
it exists in the mat the mask universe
wow that pops out here thanks
have a good one yeah that thing's been
living there for ages yeah
here you go
oh so good
hey josh look at this huge moth that i
found
isn't that cool yeah that's cool get it
out of here man
yeah it's cool but get out of here man
is it beautiful
look what i found it's the dining room
oh
that is a lovely size room yes they are
big in these houses most of them have
been converted into flats so to get one
like this bit of a lucky find
how many bedrooms is it it's two but
there is the box room which could be an
office or could be used as a third
bedroom
hmm i think we definitely need three
double bedrooms
did i ask you
where is this from dude i asked you i
feel like this is what the real estate
agents always want to do they always put
on such a smile don't they
this is great isn't it no we need
three bedrooms might be the greatest
snooker shot we'll ever see
gilbert let's go gilbert
smashed it gilbert well done hey i can
do that
i do that all the time well ain't that a
surprise
kind of warming up to this i'm not sure
so sure what i feel about it to be
honest but if you enjoyed
smash like subscribe check out g fuel
link is in the description
stock up see you tomorrow brofist